en los colegios electorales las
papeletas y las urnas están listas pero
al igual que la primera vuelta faltan
asesores que ayuden a atender las mesas
necesitamos dos asesores por colegio
electoral tenemos 70 colegios
electorales en la ciudad y hay muchos en
los que sólo hay un asesor lo mismo
ocurre en bergerac en dordoña en los
últimos días hemos tenido cancelaciones
por casos de cobijo min también es
cierto que el tiempo que se realiza la
segunda vuelta no es muy bueno en
términos de calendario tres zonas
estarán de vacaciones al mismo tiempo en
francia los asesores se eligen de tres
maneras entre los representantes de los
partidos políticos entre los votantes
locales o entre los funcionarios locales
como en el caso de friv donde el alcalde
y pidió a un administrador municipal que
ayudara en un colegio electoral
siempre es interesante poder participar
en este tipo de operaciones ver desde
dentro cómo se celebran unas elecciones
las normas del código electoral son
estrictas además de los dos asesores se
necesitan un presidente y un secretario
para gestionar las urnas la escasez de
voluntarios suele provocar una mayor
espera para los votantes